I remember when I wrote my book back in
2003 the linguistan language language
learning odyssey
I remember saying two things there that
at that time I felt very strongly about
this was before I had ever heard of
Stephen crashen and the input hypothesis
before I had heard of the three keys
your attitude the time you spend with
the language and the ability to notice I
didn't know any of those things but I
felt the two things were at least part
of My Success in learning Chinese which
I learned in less than a year up to a
level let's say four thousand characters
reading newspapers translating from
Chinese to English from English to
Chinese
uh you know newspaper editorials and
things like that
that one was intensity
and the other was the number of words I
had to learn